We're hanging in here with the awesome Lily Singh.
(audience claps)
Who I just so deeply respect and admire.
And then I discovered we share a passion!
Twins, twinsies, twinsies!
Your kitchen looks real bougie,
I'm real jealous and I'm so excited.
Yeah, it's totally bougie,
you're so right.
Cause I was like,
"I need people to get out of their houses
and into a nice destination."
But the fact that you chose to go back
into a house is just so smart.
And I love that we're both trying to figure this out
to be true to ourselves
and yet entertain people
and build a community.
I really do feel a lot of symmetry with you Lily.
I couldn't agree more.
And the fact that we're about to make cheesy mac and cheese.
And then we have the glue that truly binds.
Okay, I know you have a mac and cheese cabinet,
which is.
I do.
I mean I knew that I felt a connection to you,
but I had.
Here's the thing.
Are we doing original Kraft dinner, mac and cheese,
or are we doing like one of the other ones?
Are we doing like a creamy?
Are we doing an extra cheesy?
What are we doing here?
I'll demonstrate because I have a real passion
for the deluxe,
but what I make for my daughters
and what I've also grown up on
and I'm very passionate about is the powder.
So you say you have the perfect mac and cheese recipe
and can you take me through it,
because this is an art.
A hundred percent.
This should be on my resume.
So the pot has the pasta in it, correct?
Is it strained?
It is strained.
Amazing. Okay.
What people don't understand is you need to leave the stove
on a low temperature throughout this process.
So, but first thing I would do
is I would actually put butter.
How much?
Butter.
Don't be shy.
Okay. We're not making a salad here.
I would say like, you know, whatever makes you happy.
I'm going to get.
Okay you know what?
I'm very impressed with that amount.
That is probably double what I would put,
but I'm not mad.
I'm not mad at that.
I really like a good, like three tablespoons.
Like it's like half a stick, you know?
Cause again, Lily, this isn't salad.
Of course.
if you're gonna go, lean all the way in.
A hundred percent.
This is not the time to be dainty.
Absolutely. No.
We're making deluxe here.
We're splurging.
Okay. While this is melting,
I actually put the powder in.
So the powder and the butter can kind of be together.
And then I put a little bit of milk as well.
Yeah, there you go.
So when we do the milk,
this is where you have to go little by little.
You don't want to dump the whole thing in.
You incorporate a little bit of milk,
just a splash.
And then you start,
you start mixing to see where you're at.
That boom. I would stop right there.
Exactly. Boom.
Now. Fun fact, Kraft Macaroni & Cheese,
one of its best selling like collabs
was the SpongeBob shaped pasta.
Whew, I did not know that.
Drew, did you know that for this Valentine's day,
I heard a rumor
about they're releasing a special pink mac and cheese
that tastes like candy.
I thought it was just like red pasta with the same sauce
which I thought was really neat,
I didn't know it was sweet,
but maybe Lily we could try it
and let each other know what we think.
Yeah. I'm down.
Here's the consistency.
It's real good, real good.
Is the butter all melted?
The butter is almost all melted.
Wait, I hear you have some, can I try it?
For sure.
I hear you have some cheesy jokes.
Oh, okay. I'll give you one.
Did you hear, this' actually a real one.
Did you hear about the,
near my house there was a cheese factory that exploded?
No.
Yeah, there was debris everywhere.
(Lily laughs)
I don't know why,
but I got way too cerebral with that joke.
I was like garbage?
What does garbage have to do with that?
How is the mac and cheese?
Oh, I'm so jealous.
It's just.
It's perfect.
It's perfect the way it is.
I feel very strongly about this.
You know what else is perfect the way it is?
You.
Oh, no you.
No, you.
(audience claps)
I'm so happy that you're eating mac and cheese.
I'm living vicariously through you
and I know it's making you so happy.
So it's making me happy.
Well, let's try the Valentine's day one
and see what we think.
And then,
I'm down.
Let's be sisters on the airwaves.
For sure,
Trying to put ourselves, optimism be a part
of what really it is.
I love that we don't just show up and say our lines,
like these shows for better or worse are a huge part of us.
Yep. They become your life.
And you know,
I really appreciate you being willing also to share yourself
and being a creative force.
Having an idea and seeing it through
and showing up at the table not empty handed.
That's what you do.
And I really love it.
And be sure to check out A Little Late With Lilly Singh,
weeknights on NBC, of course.
(upbeat music)